Ein forschungsteam aus australien hat die älteste farbe der welt entdeckt hergestellt von lebewesen sie ist wohl
1,1 milliarden jahre alt und kommt aus einer zeit in der es noch keine
pflanzen oder tiere gab und die analyse lüftet so einige geheimnisse der konkrete grund dafür
und welche farben und tatsächlich die älteste aller zeiten ist klicks um science-fiction bei uns gibt es jeden tag
11 video wenn er nichts verpassen wollt dann abonniert den kanal ok let's go herzlich willkommen
Diese entdeckung erklärt die evolution neu und besser jetzt wissen wir dass vor rund einer milliarde jahren
cyanobakterien die erde bevölkerten und damit auch warum sich genau deshalb damals noch keine komplexeren lebewesen entwickeln
konnten mehrere hundert meter hatte man unter dem westafrikanischen
benin
becken gebuddelt um die jetzt entdeckten farbstoffe aufschwung eigentlich war ein großes unternehmen dort auf der suche nach
tonschichten die öl enthalten das australische forschungsteam bekam das gestein zur analyse und jürgen brocks einer der beteiligten wissenschaftler
beschreibt die krasse überraschung die dabei zutage kam ich hörte meine mitarbeiterin
schreien als die lösung heraus kam die flüssigkeit in flächen leuchtet das bringt das waren echte
uralte
farbige moleküle die ältesten der welt
das uralte gestein aus der marinen schiefer schicht hatte das forschungsteam zu pulver gemahlen und mit hilfe eines lösungsmittels
die pigmente extra jetzt sein fundort ist das riesige
sedimentbecken in westafrika das wohl vor 11 milliarden jahren entstanden das damals bedeckte ein
ozean die heutige sahara und in dem wimmelte es nur so von
winzigen bakterien die analyse der gefundenen moleküle ergab dann dass sie tatsächlich aus diesen uralten
cyanobakterien von damals stammen die farbpigmente jedenfalls sind in der konzentrierten form
blutrot bis purpur wenn sie verdünnt werden zeigen sie sich leuchtend rosa damals allerdings
leuchteten sie wohl eher blau grün doch im sediment hat nickel und vanadium
das ursprüngliche magnesium atom z tom ersetzt das führte dann zu den rosafarbenen molekülen mit dem namen
purine dazu eine der beteiligten forscherinnen nur wie nelly die leuchtend rosa pigmente sind die überreste von chlorophyll
das von cyanobakterien produziert wurde die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler wissen also jetzt dass die bakterien damals in der lage waren
photosynthese zu betreiben also den prozess den auch heutige pflanzen benutzen um durch sonnenlicht energie zu gewinnen
der ehemals blau grüne farbton war exakt
abgestimmt und ziemlich clever von der evolution denn damit konnten die bakterien perfekt die passenden wellenlängen aus dem sonnenlicht
absorbieren und die für die photosynthese benötigte energie aufnehmen diese cyanobakterien bevölkerten zu dieser zeit wohl
massenweise die ozeane ihre existenz erklärt nach annahme des forschungsteams auch warum zu dieser zeit keine tiere auf der erde lebten
denn diese wären durch die bakterien die die dominierende nahrungsquelle in den ozean bildeten niemals satt geworden eine reichere
energiequelle als die türe bakterien waren dann erst die algen die sich vor etwa 650 millionen jahren extrem schnell ausbreiteten und die
cyanobakterien in den ozean verschwinden ließen im vergleich zu den backend haben diese nämlich ein bis zu
1000 mal größeres volumen auch wenn viele alten mikroskopisch klein sind ein krasser energieschub also für die entwicklung komplexer
lebewesen dazu der forscher jochum box wir haben also nicht nur
als pinkes zeug entdeckt sondern auch geholfen zu erklären warum größere lebewesen erst zu spät in der geschichte auftaucht wow
hammer entdeckung und habe auch das fast
4000 menschen unseren englischen klicks um science-fiction kanal bereits abonniert haben wir haben es uns sehr auf klicks um zur aufgabe gemacht wissenschaft für alle
einfach zugänglich zu machen und das jetzt auch auf englisch euer feedback hilft uns dabei den kanal weiter zu verbessern
danke schon mal dafür wenn er den kanal noch nicht kennt klick gerne hier drauf schaut vorbei
und lasst uns ein abo da empfiehlt uns gerne euren englischsprachigen wissenschafts freunden und freundinnen und danke für eure unterstützung bis dann
bleibt dran